an International Conference is underway
in London to help Ukraine recover and
rebuild from the conflict Kiev says it
needs more than six billion dollars in
the next 12 months European commission
president Ursula vanderlayan has pledged
54 billion dollars for a three-year
period starting next year Washington
says it will provide 1.3 billion dollars
in additional financial assistance to
Ukraine for its reconstruction efforts
the World Bank estimates the costs of
the war at about
411 billion dollars so far Ukraine's
president appeared on video and urged
donors to take concrete steps
I want to thank you and of course I I
thank Switzerland Germany and France
Italy every country where we have agreed
on key principles for recovery at this
conference we must move from region to
agreements and from agreements to real
projects
the U.S Secretary of State said Russia
will eventually pay for the Damage Done
to Ukraine
even as we come together here in London
committed to supporting Ukraine's build
up Russia continues to try to burn it
down
so
let's be clear
Russia is causing Ukraine's destruction
and Russia will eventually bear the cost
of Ukraine's reconstruction
let's speak now to Nadine Baba who's at
the conference in London for us Nadeem
this conference raises a really
interesting question after 16 months of
war in a country as large as Ukraine you
know what's the bill how much does it
really cost to rebuild
well Cyril of course all figures are
estimates at the moment we heard from
the World Bank recently they think in
the short term the Reconstruction of
Ukraine's economy could cost uh 14
billion US dollars in total over perhaps
decades they've put the figure at more
than 400 billion U.S dollars now things
are moving and it's a mixture of money
for directly from government direct
assistance like that 1.3 billion dollars
announced by the US and Loan guarantees
prime minister Rishi sunak uh before the
two-day conference started said that
Britain was trying to arrange loan
guarantees through the World Bank to
Ukraine of more than three billion
dollars for the immediate term
um but beyond that politicians are
talking about some sort of Martial plan
type approach to Ukraine uh similar to
what happened in the rebuilding of
Germany after World War II but the
crucial difference in of course is that
the conflict in Ukraine is still ongoing
there's a lot of fear and so for example
in the last couple of hours France's
foreign minister speaking here said that
her country was going to introduce a war
Insurance mechanism which would
basically back guarantee any companies
in France pledging to invest in Ukraine
there are huge huge Investments being
talked about particularly in Tech and
the energy sector
um these These are estimates of the cost
I should point out were drawn up before
that destruction of the dam in southern
Ukraine and all probably depend on how
long the war actually continues
Nadeem tell us a bit more if you can
about this notion floated by the U.S
Secretary of State Anthony blinken that
we just played he said Russia should
ultimately pay for all of this
well look you won't find anybody here
who will say otherwise that's been
repeated by various political leaders
um who say that Russia is clearly the
aggressor and that Russia in the long
term will have to be made to pay what's
happening well already the UK for
example since the full scale Invasion
last year have seized around 23 billion
dollars in Russian assets in this
country and imposed sanctions on more
than 1500 people many of them linked to
the Russian government last month G7
leaders said that they would go ahead
and seize around 300 billion US Dollars
huge amounts of Russian assets in their
Banks and institutions uh including here
in the United Kingdom until Russia pays
for the damage that it's caused now the
European Central Bank has already warned
uh the EU that um doing so that um that
um seizing funds or taking interest
earned on in Russia and accounts and
using that directly to give to Ukraine
could actually create a lot of
instability on the markets people
wouldn't have uh confidence in the euro
currency we don't know how fast things
will move on that front but there is a
clear determination in the absence of
any Russian willingness to to to pay for
the damage as they say to actually take
tough action and to seize those those
assets which are immense just in this
country for example
reporting from London thank you very
much